que rights trans right to genocide these
are queers for Palestine protesters
we've seen a lot of this in recent weeks
the great irony that display might get
those people killed in the Gaza Strip
what appears to be lost on these
protesters is that gay and transgender
people in Palestinian territories face
an extraordinary level of persecution in
Gaza homosexuality can be punished with
years in prison you also might be
executed including by members of your
own family a few years ago Hamas the
terrorist organization that controls
Gaza tortured and killed one of its own
members for allegedly having sex with
another man not long ago in the West
Bank a young man's severed head was
found on the side of the road after he
was killed allegedly for the crime of
being gay so where do many of these
persecuted people try to get asylum in
Israel the same country these Stateside
protesters are speaking out against the
Israel Palestine conflict is complicated
this aspect of it not so much because
queers for Palestine is about as
convincing as minks for fur codes